رغم انها اللعبه الشعبيه الاولى في العالم
ويتوزع محبوها ومشجعوها والمفتنون بسحرها
على مختلف قاراته لكن البطوله الاهم في
عالم كره القدم كاس العالم وبعد اكثر من
تسعه عقود على انطلاقها تكون للمره الاولى
في العالم العربي وفيما يسمى بمنطقه الشرق
الاوسط فالحصه الاكبر على الدوام كانت من
نصيب اوروبا بالدرجه الاولى فبلادها
وملاعبها استضافت اكثر من نصف البطولات
السابقه ثالثها الامريكان بثمان بطولات في
حين تمكنت الدول مثل فرنسا وايطاليا من
استضافه البطوله لمرتين قبل ان يتم منح
شرف في تنظيمها لدول في قاره اسيا
وافريقيا اذنالت كل واحده منهم استضافه
يتيما كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان عام 2002
وجنوب افريقيا في 2010 كان لزاما اذا على
كل من يريد الاستمتاع مبارياته ومنافسات
كاس العالم في العالم العربي او ما يسميه
الغرب الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا ان
يسافر بعيدا وان يعيش اجواء البطوله في
بيئه وثقافه مختلفتين عنه قبل ان تنجح قطر
في كسر ما يمكن وصفه بمركزيه استضافه
بطولات كاس العالم وفي جذب انظار العالم
لمنطقه كان يقتصر دورها على التشجيع عن
بعد وبعد كسر رهان الاستضافه ومن ثم تحويل
الملف الذي قدم قبل 12 عاما الى واقع يجمع
كثير من المنصفين على تميزه واتقانه ورغم
اقتراب موعد اطلاق الصافره البدايه
لمونديال قطر 2022 لم يتوقف سيل
الانتقادات الاوروبيه او ما يطلق عليها من
قبل المسؤولين عن تنظيم كاس العالم قطر
2022 حملات التشويه والتحامل والهجوم
والتشكيك بطريقه لم تشهدها اي استضافه في
تاريخ بطولات كاس العالم ما دفع الرئيس
الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم جاني انفانتينو
الى شنه هجوم مضاد تجاه الاصوات الاوروبيه
متهما اياها بالنفاق فتاريخ كثير من الدول
بما فيها الاوروبيه يستحق الاعتذار وفق
رئيس الفيفا عن ما اقترفاته خلال عقود
طويله لان تعطي دروسا اخلاقيه للاخرين
[موسيقى]